hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
the 22nd of October today and you're
tuned into games like you let's talk er
done first a brief one have revealed a
new cop mood for titanfall today which
actually lets you play with friends
against AI the new mode called frontier
defense is part of what respawn is
calling titan falls biggest update ever
the AI enables mode lets for players go
up against waves of AI controlled
enemies while defending a point on an
existing game map enemies come in you
and old variations can wield all
existing weapons and are totally liable
to rodeo your titans as well there's
also a bit of tower defense involved you
can play sentry turrets to help defend
your location and some maps facilitate
more than 200 enemies at once alongside
frontier defense a new mode which
function as for player horde mode a la
Gears of War a hardcore twist on mark
the death mode and deadly ground which
is exactly what it sounds like a
glorified gamey version of the floor is
made of lava you can get all the
specific details on gamespot Nintendo
may be thinking seriously about their
next console given their been scouting
for a new console architect a vacancy
listing on linkedin calling for a lead
graphics architect in august and a
republish of that same listing this
month clued us in the role would be
filled at nintendo technology
development a washington-based R&D
subsidiary which suggests that nintendo
are looking for input from western
developers the listing calls for an
architect who can help build and
integrate system on chip architecture
which could be foreshadowing Nintendo's
next contribution to the game hardware
market finally halo 5 gameplay is coming
pretty damn soon Microsoft have
announced that a special hello fest live
stream will be happening the night
before the release of halo the master
chief collection on November 11 said
live stream is going to show off the
world premiere of
night for the TV series feature
interviews from 343 industries
developers and a first look at halo 5
multiplayer beta this will be showcased
through an exhibition match between
professional players but if you want one
of those you can get your own hands on
the beta from december 29 if you already
picked up the master chief collection
that's your question of the day let me
know if you're excited for halo 5 and
what you reckon in tender need to do for
the next console if you're after more
news things we've got stories on
gamespot's 100 our live streams is
happening right now and sunset overdrive
rewriting shooters on site that's it for
me today I'll be back again in a couple
of days with your top five show but have
a good one till then